الاف العقوبات الغربيه على روسيا مع
اندلاع حربها على اوكرانيا اواخر فبراير
الماضي
33 دوله ابرزها دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
والولايات المتحده
استهدفت العقوبات بشكل اساسي الاقتصاد
الروسي في محاوله غربيه لجعل الحرب مكلفه
اكثر لروسيا
وقد شملت العقوبات حضره
النفط والغاز هو الفحم الحجري والمعادن
ووضع سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي
وحضر استيراد التكنولوجيا
وضع قيود على الديون السياديه لروسيا وفصل
روسيا عن نظام سويفت للتعاملات الماليه
بالاضافه الى تجميد الارصده الحكوميه
الروسيه ووقف التعامل مع البنوك الحكوميه
دفعت هذه العقوبات مئات الشركات العالميه
في مختلف المجالات الى الانسحاب من السوق
الروسيه او تجميدي نشاطاتها هناك
[موسيقى]